voilà un des premiers sujets de de
protection les cadenas toujours avec
l'idée de de ralentissement surveiller
en permanence c'est la seule solution
pour les professionnels du cheval alors
que quatre cas de mutilations ont
récemment eu lieu en bourgogne dont deux
en saône et loire
cet éleveur de chevaux de sport est
inquiet il est obligé de revoir sa façon
de travailler
nous avons changé plusieurs choses tout
d'abord la visite plus régulière à des
heures complètement différente aussi
bien la nuit que la journée nous avons
sécurisé nos portails comme pose de cana
électricité nous avons couvert nos
terrains avec caméra et parfois même la
journée avec l'utilisation de drones
les éleveurs ne sont pas seuls des ronds
peuvent être effectués par les
gendarmeries sur demande
cette aporie l'équipe de descriptif
ah oui oui de la gendarmerie pour la
gendarmerie de pouvoir le déposer pour
savoir où sont au chaud ce saône et
loiriens peut en tout cas compter sur
son voisin également éleveur face à
l'actualité
la solidarité se renforce pour protéger
les chevaux les gens les voisins sont là
en disant voilà il ya il ya quelque
chose de louche ou pas je vais vous
donner une anecdote dans un de nos prêts
l'autre jour il y avait une voiture
blanche et et on est venu me le dire il
ya une beauté
bien sûr il ya des choses et il ya une
voiture blanche qui est là et c'était un
brave monsieur qui veut demander pour
aller à la pêche avec sa voiture il ya
une psychose mais faut pas qu'on
entretienne quand même ce mal être qui
est là pour l'instant des attaques
contre des chevaux se poursuivent dans
toute la france des enquêtes sont en
cours et la gendarmerie met en place une
coordination nationale pour tenter de
lutter contre ce fléau